You don't have to be a genius to know that the SARS coronavirus two pandemic is
wreaking havoc on the economy worldwide. However,
if there's one sector that is really taking a hit, it is the tourism sector.
Suddenly this activity, which was fundamental,
essential key in the economy of many countries, as our example,
Spain has practically stopped in its tracks,
taking millions and millions of jobs with it, many, many hotels, restaurants,
bars, cafes,
and a long list of businesses of all kinds have been forced to pull down their
blinds and closed their doors and friends.
Keep in mind that the impact is not only touching small businesses.
There are also large groups that are also suffering.
We only have to look at the giants of the air transport sector giants that are
very much affected by the drawing up of tourism,
but also by the collapse of business trends.
Yes.
It's true that the air transport sector accounts for barely 0.3% of the value
added to services in the ECB countries,
it is nevertheless a fundamental activity that supports millions of people and
thousands and thousands of companies whose activity depends on people being able
to move around the world.
And of course it could be a good gauge for measuring the trend of international
economic activity. But in the end,
it's pretty clear if the restrictions imposed to deal with the pandemic,
don't allow you to travel.
Or if they turn the experience of traveling into a nightmare of restrictions and
impediments,
who on earth is going to fill the planes that were once full of tourists
professionals and people looking to do business.
So how is the sector really doing what exactly has been the impact of the
coronavirus.
Friends? Yeah.
As you can imagine,
as the months go by and the situation of the crisis and restrictions continues
to be extended, the aviation sector is having an increasingly worse time.
Coronavirus airline set for worst year on record.
In this video,
we're going to give you some important details about how various companies are
dealing with this situation. And we will not only take a look at the airlines,
but also at the major aircraft manufacturers,
Boeing and Airbus manufacturers who obviously depend on the airline companies
doing well after all, remember that without passengers, there are no flights,
the flights, there are no planes and without the need for planes,
there'll be no new planes sold. Then again, does this reasoning hold up,
let's take a look.
The crisis in figures.
Pay attention to these figures because what we are going to tell you is the true
picture of what is probably already the biggest crisis we have seen and
something that we may never see again in the air transport sector,
a crisis that makes the one that occurred in the wake of the nine 11 attacks
look like a walk in the park. Take, for example,
this graph that reflects the number of flights tracked by the flight radar,
24 websites in 2019 and 20,
as you can see between March and April, 2020,
the number of air operations slumps to around a quarter of those registered in
2019. And during the rest of 2020, barely half of that loss has been recovered.
All of this obviously translates into multimillion dollar losses,
firstly for the airlines and also potentially for the aircraft manufacturers.
And of course,
for all those sectors that depend directly on this activity from the Aero
nautical Caitlin companies to the ubiquitous duty free stores,
but let's just focus on the airlines.
For now.
The recent market analysis by the ITA,
the international air transport association has tried to calculate the impact of
the pandemic. Total industry revenues are expected to fall by 46% in 2020,
compared to those of 2019 airlines faced the loss of
$314 billion in ticket sales revenue.
Putting half of the world's airlines at serious risk of bankruptcy airlines have
reduced their set supply by an average of 70% since January,
2020 and have burned through more than $10 billion a month in uncovered costs
such as aircraft leasing, maintenance, payroll fees,
and a host of other fixed costs that whether the planes fly or not have to be
dealt with, And by 2021,
the situation is not expected to be particularly buoyant either.
The forecast is for airlines to burn through a total between $5 billion and
$6 billion a month in cash. And that helps to explain what we see in this.
See,
there's a huge Gulf that only promises to become even greater considering that
2020 is not yet finished. Traditionally,
the second half is the most profitable for airlines,
but that is unlikely to be the case in the midst of new restrictions,
but friends, the impact is not only to be felt in the loss of trips.
The huge drop in demand for flights is compounded by the extra costs that the
pandemic travel brings and which may remain a heavy burden for a long time.
For example,
airlines now have to invest much more in cleaning sanitizing and disinfecting
planes, which also means spending more time on the ground and less than the air
passengers also have to spend more time on the ground because of increased
controls at airports,
which means the air connections between flights are no longer as short as they
once were without a doubt.
This poses a challenge for flight scheduling and you know,
how it goes any plane on the ground costs money,
But that's not all flood crews now also have to be provided with self filtering
masks and in many cases, goggles and even complete PPE,
almost like healthcare workers equipment that is currently in use on many Asian
airlines, such as air Asia, Korean air, and most Chinese companies.
All of these factors are just some of the many that have led companies around
the world to end up on the brink of bankruptcy or even to declare bankruptcy
already. Unfortunately,
the damage that the Corona virus is doing to the aviation industry could be in
many ways, it repairable for a certain period of time,
perhaps several years years during which the trend for low cost flights or at
least low cost in the sense we've known them could be greatly effected. Now,
will it get to that point? What effects is this crisis having on the airlines?
What role are the governments playing in all this? Well, let's take a look.
Airlines on the break.
Only two thirds of the world's 26,000 passenger aircraft grounded and some 25
million jobs at risk airlines have faced a major dilemma this 2020 find ways to
avoid closure,
even if it means resorting to bankruptcy or public Baylor mechanisms,
mechanisms that work better or worse,
depending on the country and the particular region we are talking about.
For example,
if we look at the evolution of airlines in the first months of 2020 and what
their financial risk is, we see a pattern that benefits East Asia,
but it's particularly damaging for Africa and Latin them.
Erica.
In Latin America, many airlines have already begun filing for bankruptcy,
such as AVN cause operations in the United States air in Mexico,
let's ham and team. While in Africa airlines such as South African airways,
which already had problems before the Corona virus,
ambitious and common air are in a similar situation.
And although bankruptcy does not necessarily imply the disappearance of the
company, the truth is that the issue is usually resolved in two ways,
either with the liquidation of the assets and the end of the brand or with the
financial restructuring of the debt delivery of a state aid package and if
necessary the replacement or dilution of the former shareholders.
And it is possible that it is precisely the situation that will generate
differences between some regions of the world in the near future.
Because it's clear that this drain from economic losses leaves few airlines that
will be able to weather the storm on their own without state aid in the form of
subsidies investments or loans, or at least that's what the politicians say.
You know,
Although it is true that the risk of messy bankruptcy proceedings could be
great.
The governments have done a good job in financially supporting aviation jobs
where this has not happened in Latin America. For example,
we see bankruptcies airlines continue to burn through cash,
and that is expected to persist into next year without a second traunch of
financial aid. Many airlines will not make it through the winter.
Alexandra at the uni ACC director general of the international air transport
association.
Not only does this risk that once again,
we taxpayers will end up paying the price for our politicians decisions,
but it also risks falling back into the catastrophic renationalisation policies
of many airlines, of course, apart from that potential risk airlines,
as you can imagine, support public rescues at all costs,
According to them in this case,
it is not that a company is performing badly and is going bankrupt,
but that the health measures imposed by governments,
such as confinements quarantines, curfews, hotel closures,
and other measures taken to combat the pandemic directly attack the business of
the airlines, which above all depends on transporting tourists and people.
In other words,
it is not that one or another company is sinking due to bad management,
but rather than this very special situation, that few companies in the sector,
however much cash and savings they have will be able to bear on their own for
the airlines.
It has meant putting a hold on their source of income while expenses continue to
run high.
But let's say that to be more or less than supportive public bailouts depend on
each airline.
And I suppose also on how that support materializes nonrefundable aid is
not the same as loans with preferential conditions.
The fact is that in the first six months of 2020 alone,
the world's airlines have received $162 billion in state aid,
a huge amount of money of which they have already consumed around 80%.
And of course, if we consider the air,
traffic is not expected to return to 2019 levels until at least 2020 for more
money will be needed, much more money.
But the question is, what else is being done besides transferring public money?
Well, check this out.
Cathay Pacific is regional carrier and 8,500 jobs,
BBC Korean air to buy Asiana emerges as world's 10th
largest airline Yonhap news agency.
China's top airline returns to profit as domestic routes, bloom Nikkei Asia.
I stopped to think about it for a moment.
These three new stories may represent the living image of what the aviation
market is going to be like over the next few years.
It's a market that faces several challenges,
cuts in flight frequencies and less supply,
which will mean less employment in the sector, elimination of subsidiaries,
especially those in the low cost market re centralization of the parent
companies, mergers of companies to create larger and stronger entities,
which will greatly reduce competition and the war for low prices.
And finally a turn towards the Chinese market,
especially for aircraft manufacturers in this last point above all that may
prove key to the future of Boeing and Airbus.
The two main aircraft manufacturers,
which have seen their orders for a new aircraft cancellations multiply in recent
months,
it's Boeing and Airbus that are the next link in this chain of crisis in a
faltering market.
So what does the future hold for the world's two leading aircraft manufacturers?
Well, let's take a look.
Please buy my planes.
If there's one thing that Boeing would have wanted to avoid at all costs,
it is precisely a global pandemic.
Those of you who have been following visual politics for some time now,
we'll know in detail,
what has happened to Boeing in recent years due to the disaster of its seven 37
max model, the defects in the seven, eight, seven,
and the delay in the launch of the triple seven X and the crisis that all this
has generated for the company. Well, on top of that crisis,
we must now add that of the SARS cov to a crisis that given the uncertainty of
its flagship model translates into news like this.
Boeing suffers second consecutive month with no airline orders,
the associated press.
Something that by the way, had not happened since 1962. And as you can imagine,
not selling anything for two months as a,
for any company let alone for one like Boeing that was already seriously
affected by damage done in 2019.
Look.
To the third quarter of 2020,
Boeing has lost more than $3.5 billion while in 2019,
it earned $444 million,
which was already a long way from the 8.35 billion earned in profits from the
same time period in 2018, all of those losses accumulated in 2020,
nearly 3 billion occurred in the fateful second quarter when the most severe
period of the global confinement was being experienced. In addition,
the difficult situation faced by airlines has resulted in cancellation of
aircraft orders. Boeing, for example,
already has a net loss of 1020 orders and had only sold 67 aircraft
up to the October, 2020. What's more,
it has only delivered 111 aircraft in that period compared to the 321
last year for the same timeframe,
These results.
It is not surprising that Boeing is going to lay off more than 30,000 workers
worldwide, which will mean getting rid of 18.7% of its entire workforce.
Yes, it's true that in the medium and longterm,
everything will return back to normal. In fact,
the recovery of the aviation sector in a year's time may see an increase in
orders because at the end of the day,
planes need to be renewed sooner rather than later.
But the pitcher in the short term is not so rosy
At Airbus, you got a hand,
things seem to be going a little better and they will come out of the crisis in
a slightly stronger position. Although of course,
this doesn't mean that it isn't effecting them,
but having been the go-to manufacturer for airlines that wanted medium range
aircraft after the Boeing seven 37,
max fiasco has also given them some orders and deliveries
Between January and October. Airbus has delivered 413 aircraft. Yes,
413 compared to 111 from Boeing. It's not bad, don't you think?
But even so that's 234 less than the number delivered between January
and October, 2019.
And Airbus has also had to cut jobs it as announced 15,000 layoffs,
worldwide equating to 11% of its work.
Of course.
So you see the aviation crisis is here and everything points to it.
Being here to stay at least for a while, in any case,
it is almost certain that the aircraft manufacturers will recover better than
the airlines, particularly because there are countries like China,
where the demand for airplanes has not only not fallen, but continues to grow.
The Asian.
We'll buy 8,600 new planes by 2039 worth about
1.4 trillion. Yes,
that's with a T if Boeing soon overcomes the effects of the grounding of the
seven 37 maxes,
which it seems we will soon see flying again and Airbus manages to save star
programs like the 82 20,
the near future for both manufacturers may not be so bad after all,
but that is if you're looking particularly at Asia, however,
in the airline industry, there is a long way to go.
The big debts they are facing in order to maintain their fleets,
jobs and face fixed costs will drag them down for many years.
If we also add to this, the mergers and takeovers, that undermined competition,
which is unavoidable in the short and medium term,
the things get even worse for the passengers.
The only hope for airlines today is to fight back by raising prices and reducing
costs. For example,
by eliminating free passenger services and making travelers pay all that.
Of course, if they manage to get some government help, but at this point,
we want to hear from you.
Do you think that the coronavirus will change the world of aviation for river or
where we go back to traveling as before,
could this pandemic push Airbus into the role of the world's leading aircraft
manufacturer, if your answers in the comments.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit, like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and there were patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.